dr. strange might be able to enter the
mirror dimension Dark Dimension and
astral plane but he also successfully
transcended to a new level of existence
that is just as impressive the marvel
cinematic universe if you're not a
sorceress apprentice yourself though you
might have missed some of the finer
details of the film's finale but don't
worry we've got you covered
he is the ending of Doctor Strange
explain the secret of the I don't tell
fan ass but the eye of agamotto is
actually an infinity stone the time
stone to be precise for those of you
keeping score at home that's the fifth
of the six Infinity stones to appear in
a Marvel movie so far the mine stone is
in visions forehead the power stone is
held by the Nova Corps the space stone
is an Asgard vault and the reality
stones with the collector and since
Thanos needs all six to complete his
Infinity Gauntlet that means dr.
strangers on a collision course with the
biggest body in the known universe
pretty sweet the broken watch sorry dr.
Palmer but after the film's first 20
minutes it was safe to say that Stephen
strange will always be married to his
work not you nevertheless he still wears
to watch she gave him in order to
remember that great gal who stuck by his
side even back when he was acting like a
total Sherlock there are other things
that can give your life meaning
like what like you and this is the part
where you apologized but that's not all
the watch symbolizes the shattered face
broken in his car accident as a reminder
of how pride goeth before a fall while
the inscription on the back also prompts
strange to use the time reversing powers
of the eye of agamotto to defeat
Dormammu the watch may be broken but
thanks to its many meanings the earth is
still ticking the sanctum sanctorum
castelia sand his cronies destroyed the
London sanctum ruining a good portion of
karma Tosh in the process and while the
hong kong sanctum was saved with all
that time trickery it still took a
severe beating courtesy of dormammu's
henchmen so at the end of the movie it
appears that dr. Strange's decided to
abandon the Ancient Ones tradition of
living in Tibet and instead has made New
York his full-time headquarters just
like in the comics he probably does want
a better broadband what's this my mantra
the Wi-Fi password we're not savages
succeeding the sorcerer supreme with the
ancient one gone the world heavyweight
title of source for a supreme is
basically being passed down to the
doctors broken hands and whether or not
it's official he's definitely earned it
he stopped kuselias came to a stalemate
of Dormammu he fixed the hong kong
sanctum he was chosen by the cloak of
levitation and he saved the planet he
still maintains vigilance over karma
Tosh and the New York sanctum to boot
and according to the mid-credits scene
he's already fulfilled his duties by
safeguarding earth from threats like
Loki
thanks doc Baron Mordo so why did Baron
Mordo turn his back on Doctor Strange at
the end and then turn into a straight-up
villain in the post-credits scene
because it was fated not by a magic
prophecy but by the comics just like in
the movie comic book Mordor was the
Ancient Ones apprentice but he
eventually went bad and became dr.
Strange's archenemy based on the
post-credits scene it seems like movie
Mordor was going down the same path
meaning we expect to see a lot more of
him in the sequel as a bad guy it wasn't
clear
it was sorted thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and watch more videos
like the one you just saw
and don't forget to check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
you